now when actors do films like that you
know you guys you know what your look at
you because you've seen films like that
cuz like okay it's gonna be amazing
but what did you think you were looking
at did you think it was gonna be that I
can tell you what I was talking at and
and you know it looks pretty it looks
simple enough but actually what I'm
looking at is Steven Spielberg with the
big long stick with a tennis ball at the
air just waiting it like this you know
you have to look as span not easy this
term is it no it's like that's like a
master class in amazement now I'm going
to ask around a question and I think I
know the answer would you like to do a
bit of acting with Sam Neill no okay
could you recreate the look of amazement
so better you look over the two of you
look I've got props in general I've got
props oh I've got I've got a look I've
got I've got the Laura Dern leaf blower
glasses you've got as much res little
there as you want to put on there you go
okay so they're preparing on okay and by
the way at the end when they when
they're looking suitably and amazed no I
know annoyed by the dinosaur it's
slowing traffic down
stupid things who brought them back so
if you using your vocal training do a
little bit of dinosaur eat a bit of
dinosaur toys help and measurably
actually I'll do it can you indirect
this please yes okay to our music we
start the music
marry the time this is kind of right
behind on behind you behind you see
you're looking behind the camera yeah
this is a murican out the way cuz I'm
only doing okay so it's a very small
dinosaurs you know it'll it'll into
until a classic camera right okay can I
just check in one that's for sake just
VMAs
[Applause]
how you do it you it
that's very good that's very helpful
I'm starting the music I'm not being
really bad tennis ball
about you to q4 sound okay let me say
action action
Oh
[Applause]
very good excellent oh good work
everyone but it's very hard to corral
actors isn't it like herding cats
you